[Music]
foreign
view a first look at what is on the
front pages time then to see what's
making the headlines with the guardian's
political editor pipakrira and the
telegraph's chief political
correspondent Camilla Turner welcome to
both of you uh with us from now until
just before midnight so from Pages then
let us kick off with the Metro it leads
with the Fallout after a serving met
police officer David Carrick admitted
committing 49 offenses including 24
counts of rape that story also the lead
as you can see for the guardian a met
officer admits to a brutal Campaign Of
Terror the Sun pictures Carrick in
uniform describing him as the monster of
the met the express asking the big
question how did the Met police miss a
serial rapist in its ranks The Daily
Mirror says that the force had nine
chances to stop Carrick but failed to
act every time
the telegraph quoting the Met
commissioner admitting that his Force
failed and that Carrick should never
have been one of its officers
another big question how many more the
eye reporting that around 800 met
officers are currently under
investigation for alleged sexual or
domestic abuse
The Daily Mail puts that figure at
closer to 1600.
the times meanwhile focusing on the new
round of teacher strikes that have been
announced saying they will hit millions
of pupils the financial times has word
of a pricing dispute involving U.S drug
manufacturers who supply to the National
Health Service and the Daily Star has
details of the arrest of a leading
Italian mafia boss
well a reminder by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers while you watch us
so let's head straight to Our Guest then
papakura and Camilla Turner welcome as I
said to both of you
um huge uh dominating one story
dominating rather Pippa that of the Met
officer and your paper suggesting um
admitted to this brutal campaign of rape
and Terror over so many years
yeah that's the astonishing thing about
this is that this man is one of
Britain's
um mysterious sex offenders and yet he
was a police officer and not just any
police officer he was part of an elite
unit that was protecting Parliament
diplomats and and Senior politicians he
had he was armed and he used
um the the court to the courts that
heard um he used his position when it
came to first of all
um getting a loan with women and then
subsequently
um convincing them that uh he that if
they didn't do what he said then you
know who would believe who would believe
them and went up against a a member of
an Elite Police Unit
um and it's the length of time and the
number of women that were affected by
this there was
um 85 serious offenses over 17 years
including 48 drapes and not just that I
think the thing which most people will
be concerned about tonight is obviously
the horrors of this particular
individual and the and the sort of the
violence and fear that he has that he's
spread but also the fact that the Met
ignored warnings on eight occasions
about his behavior over that 20-year
period
um and as as the seriousness severity of
his crimes escalated
he managed to evade a whole a whole host
of of points where
um they could have they could have uh
worked out what was going on and and
acted on some of
um you know during vetting process
processes and so on they could have
acted on on some of the allegations and
it is astonishing and frankly the number
10 said earlier today that it was going
to shatter public confidence in the
police which is already as we all know
um the Metropolitan Fleet forces had a
whole series of of uh of difficult
incidents over the past few years
um public trust in the police is very
low this is going to really make it a
whole lot harder for them to to win back
the trust despite Mark Riley's attempts
um and you know it's really a major
crisis Point yes and uh you know the
newspapers will no doubt go into all of
these incidents where he could have been
caught uh you said hey the mirror though
I think as nine doesn't it but your
paper the guardian suggesting they've
obtained the first account from a woman
who says the Firearms officer sent her
selfies from work in his uniform some
showing his met issue gun and later
threatened to murder her saying I can
kill you without leaving any evidence
she claimed that he restrained her with
his police as she can calves and boasted
that he was a powerful man who guarded
the Prime Minister I mean in a senior
role there as you can see the picture of
the Guardian there David Carrick been
promoted to an elite armed unit of the
Metropolitan Police in 2009 so you know
will there be an investigation into
these missed opportunities do you think
Camilla
um which should ring alarm Bells no
doubt within the force
um yes we've started we had calls today
um from politicians for a wide-ranging
inquiry to be carried out
um into the map police about why it is
that over the last two decades they've
missed so many warnings about
um one of one of the UK's most prolific
serial rapists who who came from within
their own ranks and conservative MPS I
was speaking to today were saying how
can the public possibly have confidence
in the map police to solve these crimes
in the country when they can't even spot
it or even worse failed to act on
multiple red flags
um of someone from from within their own
Force so I think this is something that
we're going to see a lot of Fallout over
the coming days
um and I think even more calls for for
senior members of the map police to be
held for account for any failings and
any missed warnings that they've had
over the years
um about this policeman well the uh the
newish if I can put it that uh
commissioner of the Mets and Mark Rowley
took over in in sept chamber is quoted
in the Daily Telegraph for saying this
man Abused Women in the most disgusting
manner we have failed but also the paper
points out that he previously held the
role of assistant commissioner for
specialist operations at the Met which
carrick's unit came under
um so you know presumably there won't be
direct questions to him but there are
lots of questions now about whether
there should be mandatory vetting of all
officers in the met or indeed I think
his labor suggested pepper throughout
the country
yes because all the focuses on the
Metropolitan Police here as a result of
as a result of David Carrick but um
there of course we've seen examples of
abuse and misogyny racism at forces
right across the country which is which
have all helped um solid the police's
name and you know I do think it is worth
saying that despite this horrific case
there are masses of police officers out
there who do an incredible job on not
much money and go Way Beyond
um the Call of Duty to um to keep the
public safe and we've all encountered
them in our everydays and
um it but it does it is incredibly
worrying that this man got away in this
force with this for so long and it
suggests that it's not just as simple as
senior police officers turning around to
say this is One Bad Apple that there are
some institutional feelings here that um
that have let him slip through the net
and continue on this committing these
crimes many of which are in London but
also some of them which were in
Hertfordshire which is where he lived
um and seems to have and has got away
you know had got away with until this
point and um as Camilla says there are
various calls from politicians to
conduct an inquiry into into how this
happened the Met is no stranger to these
sorts of inquiries has brought in some
recent changes including
um one on the police dismissal process
which is the home office were expecting
to hear more from that shortly
um and you know you can only imagine
that that the forensic height that has
already been cast Over The Met will only
intensify after this Mark Rowley as he
said has just taken over five months ago
departure request to Dick after London
mayor said he can lost faith in her
um Mark really has taken over he's a
very experienced police officer but I
think even he recognizes it says on the
front page of the telegraph there that
apologies that aren't really going to
cut it at the moment when it comes back
to restoring faith particularly with
with women who live in the metropolitan
police in the metropolitan police area
um and I think it is you know said sort
of a crisis for policing and
unfortunately I think that's true and
that wouldn't just be restricted to the
med I think there's gonna there's a huge
amount of work that they're going to
have to undertake over probably a very
long period uh to convince a lot of
people that as a force they are they're
prepared unwilling to root out this sort
of behavior where it exists
yes in a stark front page from The Daily
Mail uh just on this just how many more
monsters in uniform are suggesting that
the med said it was now reviewing
1633 cases involving
1071 of its officers and staff who face
complaints of domestic abuse or sexual
offending over the past decade but we
move on Camilla to the latest news which
is in the times and in fact the front
page two of the Delhi Telegraph uh Mass
workouts by teachers now a prospect a
suggestion is it will hit millions of
pupils um no one quite knows how this
will work I guess and whether
um enforce school closures will happen
but we wait to see
um yes that's right this is um today um
late afternoon we have the news that um
the National Education Union which is
the biggest Union in the UK for teachers
um met the threshold and voted in favor
of strike action so
um that could potentially see school
closures the leaders of the Union I was
speaking to earlier today said that in
schools where they've only got a few
union members they could probably stay
open but in a school where the majority
of teachers are members of the NAU that
would most probably lead to the school
having to close and we actually saw the
department for Education
um has released its guidance for schools
on how to try and keep the show on the
road and drawing these strikes and
they're saying it may be necessary to
switch to remote learning
um schools might want to think about
bringing in volunteers
um also prioritizing vulnerable children
and and those studying for their gcses
and a levels um if they do have to pick
and choose which children are able to be
in school obviously this is going to be
a complete nightmare for working parents
who will potentially you have to take
the day off work so they can look after
their children yes I take the view it's
rather more significant for parents than
pupils in some respect I have to say but
we we will see um whether they'll cope
with the laptops and volunteers to help
schools hit by strikes as the Daily
Telegraph suggested is on offer for
young people Pippa
well you know that should that should do
it I mean bottom line is it's it is
disruptive for parents I think it's um I
think many of them who have have
children at uh exam stage will be
particularly concerned I'm sure my
children won't suffer too much not being
at that stage having having you know a
couple of days off school and it's um
yes it's disruptive but also teachers
aren't striking for the sake of it and I
think that what they would say with the
Unions would say is that they
um that this is really Last Resort that
it's really reached a point where uh
because of pay and crucially because of
retention they don't see any other
course of action now as as you've all
you know as many of your viewers will
know retention is a massive issue facing
the teaching profession which uh any of
us that have kids at school or friends
or teachers know that how hard um the
vast majority of teachers work Way
Beyond their hours and that they don't
necessarily get a huge amount of you
know Financial
um they don't get a huge amount
financially from it most of them seem to
do it for the love of the job and they
are obviously a key to key to public
service and if you think that Richardson
example has plans to expand maths
teaching all the way up to to 18 for
children well that is going to require
their attention or indeed the
recruitment of Math teachers which have
fallen since 2010 so you know there are
serious issues facing the profession
that this is ultimately what this is
about and you know whether children miss
a day or two here or there what it comes
down to really I think is more sort of a
long-term sustainable future for
teaching
um and you know we're going to be we're
going to be in quite a quite a situation
if if we can't if there aren't enough
teachers to fill those vacancies
um obviously it's also about Pay
Teachers like other parts of the public
sector have had below inflation pay
Rises um and uh overall uh real terms
pay cuts
um for several years and uh clearly cost
of living crisis is hitting teachers
just is is hitting anybody else but it
does feel doesn't it that this is part
of this sort of rolling program of
strikes that we've seen first class
transport which is near resolution then
everyone's in nurses and health nurses
today has said that they're going to
There's issues some more strike dates um
should and much more widespread
widespread Spike dates
um unless the government unless they
managed to reach a resolution with the
government for the end of January and
now we have teachers
um you know this this sort of this
strikes issue and the resolution of them
despite where she selects apparent
attempts to to talk with the unions
isn't isn't there yet
um and I think that ongoing disruption
not just schools but across the public
sector uh Property Services that are
provided is going to continue and that's
damaging for the government yes and the
suggestion is that the National
Education Union May well have a meeting
with gunbund on on Wednesday but yet
again yet another Union uh Camilla
talking about 13 years of underfunding
effectively doing secure stama's job for
for him
um and what does this mean as we roll
forwarded towards the night election
Rishi sunak a furlough long forgotten
does not want to be the PM with the
reputation for bringing public services
to their knees so what does he do about
it
um yes absolutely the longer these
strikes go on and the more public sector
unions they um impact on
um the weaker it looks for the
government quite frankly if it's a
government that can't keep schools open
can't keep the transport Network working
um can't keep the postal Network working
um can't essentially operate basic
Public Services under its watch then
that's not a particularly good look for
for Rishi sunak and it's interesting
with strikes because it's actually an
area where we see quite a key Divergence
between
um the Tories and the labor Party
conservatives are wanting to or are
today and bring in these tougher strike
laws whereas labor talking about
repealing the 2016 Trade union act
um and that they're saying they don't
support the the government stance on on
the new Strength laws it's bringing in
um of course whether
um if they're in power laid would be
able to avert these strikes as sort of
hypothetical at this stage but the fact
that the conservatives are in Downing
Street and are unable to prevent these
months now of rolling public sector
strikes is not a good look and not
something that goes down particularly
well with voters either yes and we saw
that majority of 60 for the government
in that second reading vote result on
their strikes minimum service levels
Bill moves on to the committee stage we
are told so lots more of that obviously
in the days to come lots more in our
program too at the UK government blocks
Scotland's gender recognition bill in a
first since Evolution we'll discuss that
[Music]
foreign
the Press preview with me once again
peppercura and Camilla Turner welcome
back to both of you
um to the guardian Pippa if you don't
mind your paper
um and uh apologies because you're
Scottish I've picked you to do this one
uh this is the fact that the UK
government has blocked a law made in
Scotland on gender recognition but it's
the first time since Devolution that
they've stepped in in this way
yeah this is part of the Scotland act
which is obviously the act under which
Devolution happened in section 35 order
is kind of the nuclear option that the
Scottish secretary has decided to take
and it's a because the Scottish
government the Scottish Parliament and
it's backed by all the parties apart
from the Tories uh um past legislation
to make Scotland the first part of the
UK to introduce the self-identification
system for transgender people who wanted
to change gender and what the Scottish
what the UK government is saying is that
this would have an adverse impact on UK
legislation the equality the equality
act um as it as it's um imposed across
the rest of the UK and that they have a
a responsibility to protect the
Devolution settlement so they're
basically saying this is all about the
Constitutional impact of it but when
Nicholas sturgeon and the Scottish
government are saying two things one is
that this is actually a slippery slope
to them undermine the Democratic will of
the Scottish Parliament which voted by
majority to bring this legislation in
and two that is an attack on trans
people and that uh and the the UK
government is attempting to make this a
sort of a another step in the culture
war war and there's definitely an
element of that in all of this um but
this value is going to continue I think
for some time uh in Parliament tomorrow
and then beyond yeah we'll see what
happens next certainly on that one uh in
the meantime Jeremy Clarkson
um a full public apology to the Duke and
Duchess of Sussex or specifically The
Duchess I suppose uh which is it seems
been somewhat rejected by them Camilla
um yes that's right we had them Jeremy
Clarkson today issuing
um yet another apology
um to Harry and Megan and revealing that
he'd actually emailed them both on
Christmas day to tell him to to tell
them personally how sorry he was for
this column and how sort of mortified he
was and at the amount of offense it had
caused
um but Harry and Megan are saying that
this doesn't cut it they're not
interested
um sort of rejecting his apology
um and we also learned today it was
reported that Amazon are likely to be
dropping Jeremy Clarkson when his
current contract comes to an end so it's
not good news for him it seems all his
apologies have
um sort of fallen on deaf ears
um and it looks like it's going to be
quite difficult potentially for him to
recover from all of this yes he claimed
he wrote it in a rush and didn't realize
he'd completely messed up until reading
the paper but their statement says it is
clear that this is not an isolated
incident shared in haste but rather a
series of Articles shared in hate so
quite a put down from them to him both
of you thank you both very much indeed
Camilla Turner there and peppercura we
will see you later thank you very much
indeed let's